At Medcan, we know that life's greatest moments are built on a foundation of good health, from the big milestones to the quiet winds. That's why our annual health assessment offers a physician-led, full-body checkup that provides a clear picture of your health today, and may uncover early signs of conditions like heart disease and cancer. The healthier you means more moments to cherish. Take control of your well-being and book an assessment today. Medcan. Live well for life.
在Medcan，我们深知人生最伟大的时刻建立在健康的基础之上，从重大的里程碑到宁静的微风，莫不如此。正因如此，我们的年度健康评估提供由医生主导的全身检查，为您呈现当下的健康状况，并可能及早发现心脏病和癌症等疾病的迹象。您越健康，就越有更多值得珍惜的时刻。掌控您的健康，立即预约评估。Medcan，为您的一生健康生活。
Visit medcan.com slash moments to get started. King of England and you, Duke of Bedford, who call yourself regent of the Kingdom of France, you, William Paul, Count of Suffolk, John Tolbott, and you, Thomas Lord scales, who call yourselves lieutenants of the said Duke of Bedford, make satisfaction to the king of. heaven. Surrender to the maid who is sent here by God, the king of heaven, the keys of all the good towns which you have taken and violated in France. She is come here by God's will to reclaim the
访问 medcan.com/moments 开始。英格兰国王，以及自称法兰西王国摄政的贝德福德公爵，还有萨福克伯爵威廉·波尔、约翰·托尔博特，以及自称上述贝德福德公爵副官的托马斯·斯凯尔斯勋爵，你们要向天国之王做出补偿。向天国之王派遣至此的圣女投降，交出你们在法国夺取并蹂躏的所有城镇的钥匙。她是奉上帝的旨意来到这里，为
kingdom for its rightful king. She is perfectly ready to make peace if you are willing to grant her satisfaction by abandoning France and paying for what you have held. And you, Artur's, at war, gentlemen and others, who are before the town of O'Leon, get going back to your own country in the name of God. And should you not do so, then expect tidings from the maid who will come to see you shortly to your very great arm. King of England, if you do not do so, I am a captain of war, and in whatever place I meet your people in France, I shall compel them to depart, whether they want to or not. And if they refuse to obey, then I will have them all put to death. I am sent here by God, the king of heaven, to drive you out of France. So that's one of the most remarkable
合法的国王收复王国。如果您愿意通过放弃法国并为您所占领的一切做出赔偿来满足她的要求，她完全准备好实现和平。还有你们，在奥尔良城前的阿图尔战争绅士及其他人，以天主之名回到你们自己的国家去。如果你们不这样做，那么就等着圣女的消息吧，她很快就会来见你们，让你们遭受巨大的伤害。英格兰国王，如果您不这样做，我是一名战争统帅，无论我在法国的什么地方遇到你们的人，我都会强迫他们离开，不管他们是否愿意。如果他们拒绝服从，那么我将把他们全部处死。我是天国之王派遣至此，将你们驱逐出法国。所以，这是历史上最引人注目的
letters in history. And it was dictated, not written, dictated, on the 22nd of March 1429 by an illiterate peasant girl to the king of England and his captains who were in France. And these captains since the previous October 1428 had been laying siege to the city of Orleans on the river Loire, the lynch pin of the front line between the English and dauphin held possessions in France. Now, by the spring of 1429, the city of Orleans seemed about to fall. And if it did fall, then the English would be able to drive a stake into the heart of their enemy's holdings and possibly bring an end at last to the noble crusade of the Hundred Years' War. But this peasant girl, Tom, had other ideas. Now, who on earth is she? Who are we talking about?
信件之一。它是由一位文盲农家少女在1429年3月22日口述的，而不是写下的，对象是当时身处法国的英格兰国王及其统帅们。自1428年10月以来，这些统帅们一直在围攻卢瓦尔河畔的奥尔良市，这是英格兰人和法国王太子所控制领地之间前线的枢纽。到了1429年春天，奥尔良城似乎即将陷落。如果它陷落了，英格兰人就能在敌人的领地中心钉下一颗钉子，并可能最终结束百年战争这场高尚的十字军东征。但是，汤姆，这个农家少女有不同的想法。那么，她到底是谁？我们在谈论谁？
Well, she is, of course, it will stun our listeners to learn, Joan of Arc, or as she called herself, Jean Lapucel the maid. And in our previous episode, we described her background. We described her childhood. She'd been born in a village called Don Remy on the war-torn eastern margins of France. She's a peasant girl. And so, by definition, she hasn't learned to ride a horse. She's not practiced in the handling of arms. But then at the age of 13, she hears a voice that she says has come from heaven, and these are soon to become voices in the plural. And by 1428, these voices are telling her to lead an army to Ollion and to break the English siege. And so she obeys.
嗯，她当然是——这会让我们的听众感到震惊——圣女贞德，或者正如她自称的那样，让娜·拉·普塞尔（Jean La Pucelle），即“圣女”。在上一集中，我们描述了她的背景。我们描述了她的童年。她出生在法国东部饱受战争蹂躏的边缘地带一个叫栋雷米的小村庄。她是个农家女孩。因此，按照定义，她没有学过骑马。她没有练习过武器的使用。但在13岁那年，她听到了一种她说来自天堂的声音，这些声音很快变成了复数。到了1428年，这些声音告诉她要率领一支军队前往奥尔良，打破英格兰人的围攻。于是她服从了。
And she sets out on this mission in February 1429. She has a horse. She's riding it. And she sets off on what is a very long and dangerous journey through terrorism. infested by bandits and men-at-arms, partisans of the hostile Duke of Burgundy. And it's an astonishing mission. And the one thing we've not done is to describe Joan, to make her come alive for our listeners. So give us a sense of how she looked, you know, what you'd have seen, if you looked up from
她在1429年2月开始了这项使命。她有一匹马。她骑着它。她踏上了一段漫长而危险的旅程，穿越被土匪和武装人员、敌对的勃艮第公爵的党羽所盘踞的恐怖地带。这是一项令人惊叹的使命。我们唯一还没做的事情就是描述贞德，让我们的听众感受到她的存在。所以，给我们描述一下她的样子，你知道，如果你从
your job, as you would undoubtedly have been doing Tom, you'd have been tilling the fields had you lived in the Middle Ages because you're a man of the soil, orny-handed son of its oil. not cut out for life as a cleric. So you'd have been working probably near the bottom of the social spectrum. And you'd have looked up and you'd have seen this person passing. What would you have seen? The descriptions of Joan are kind of scanty and not entirely reliable. But she seems to have been dark-haired and she has cut this hair,
你的工作中抬头看，汤姆，你无疑会这样做，如果你生活在中世纪，你肯定会是在耕种田地，因为你是一个土地之子，一个长满老茧的土地之子。不适合做神职人员。所以你可能是在社会底层工作。你会抬头看到这个人经过。你会看到什么？关于贞德的描述有些匮乏，而且并不完全可靠。但她似乎是深色头发，而且她剪了头发，
cropped it short in the style of a knight. Someone who knew her well, her future squire, described her as being beautiful and well-formed. And she does seem to have been attractive. But she is not dressed as a woman. She is dressed as a man. And specifically, she is wearing hose. She's wearing britches.
剪成了骑士风格的短发。一个很了解她的人，她未来的侍从，形容她美丽且体态匀称。她看起来确实很有吸引力。但她没有穿女装。她穿的是男装。具体来说，她穿着紧身裤。她穿着马裤。
And these are both tightly knotted into a kind of a gray doublet. And this is obviously to guard herself against sexual assault. And over this doublet, she wears a black tunic and she has a black cloak. She also has a hat. It's made of wool. Again, it's black. And she's pulled this over her hair. as we said she's riding a horse
这些都紧紧地系在一种灰色的紧身上衣里。这显然是为了保护自己免受性侵犯。在这件紧身上衣外面，她穿着一件黑色束腰外衣，披着一件黑色斗篷。她还有一顶帽子。它是羊毛做的。同样是黑色的。她把它拉过头发。正如我们所说，她骑着马，
even though she had never ridden one before and it seems that over the course of this journey she becomes actually a very good horsewoman she's got a sword by her side the marker of a knight and in her train she has two pages and four men at arms I mean it's a long all journey
尽管她以前从未骑过马，但看起来在这次旅程中，她实际上成为了一名非常出色的女骑手。她腰间挂着一把剑，这是骑士的标志，在她的随从中有两名侍从和四名武装人员。我的意思是，这是一段漫长的旅程，
250 miles and they ride mostly by night presumably to avoid detection and to avoid bandits and Burgundians and they cross the Loire and it takes them 10 days and then finally they reach a shrine, Saint-Catharine de Fierbois.
250英里，他们大多在夜间骑行，大概是为了避免被发现，避开土匪和勃艮第人。他们穿过卢瓦尔河，花了10天时间，最后他们到达了一个圣地，圣凯瑟琳·德·菲耶布瓦（Saint-Catherine de Fierbois）。
And what's the point of this shrine? Why this shrine in particular? Well, it's sacred to St. Catherine, who we know from later records is very important to Joan, but St. Catherine at Fiabois is also very important to prisoners of war who have escaped from the English. They see the St. Catherine in this shrine as their particular patron.
这个圣地有什么意义？为什么偏偏是这个圣地？嗯，它是圣凯瑟琳的圣地，我们从后来的记录中知道她对贞德非常重要，但菲耶布瓦的圣凯瑟琳对那些从英格兰人手中逃脱的战俘也非常重要。他们将这个圣地的圣凯瑟琳视为他们特别的守护神。
And so there are all kinds of fetters that they've hung up to mark their liberation. And so it's a very Joan place to make a halt. And at this shrine, she dictates a letter to the man who she has come to see, the man that she acknowledges as being the rightful king of France. And this is Charles of Valois. So he is the son of the previous king, Charles VI. He is the heir to the ancestral dynasty that has been sitting on the throne of France and which has been replaced by the House of Lancaster, the English dynasty. And he's not Charles the 7th yet. I mean, he should be Charles the 7th, but everyone calls him the Dofant because they think the English have the upper hand and that he's basically, you know, he's doomed to fail, right? Well, I mean, legally, if you're a supporter of Charles, he is Charles the 7th. But he is widely called the Dofant, I think, for a number of reasons.
所以那里挂着各种各样的镣铐来纪念他们的解放。所以这是一个非常适合贞德停留的地方。在这个圣地，她口述了一封信给那个她来见的人，那个她承认是法国合法国王的人。这就是瓦卢瓦的查理。所以他是前任国王查理六世的儿子。他是那个一直坐在法国王位上，并被兰开斯特家族（英格兰王朝）所取代的祖传王朝的继承人。他现在还不是查理七世。我的意思是，他本应该是查理七世，但每个人都叫他“王太子”（Dauphin），因为他们认为英格兰人占了上风，他基本上，你知道，注定要失败，对吧？嗯，我的意思是，从法律上讲，如果你是查理的支持者，他就是查理七世。但我认为人们普遍称他为“王太子”是有几个原因的。
He doesn't have a kingly air. He's physically unprepossessing people who've seen the first series of Blackadder. He looks a bit like that. More germainly, he lives under the shadow of a terrible crime, notorious crime, which is the murder at a peace summit back in 1419 of John the Fearless, the Duke of Burgundy, who had been the most powerful nobleman in France. He's got holdings that are not just in the east of France, but in the low countries as well. And it was this murder that had driven the son of John the fearless, Philip, who Subrake is the good, to enter his alliance with the English. And as you said, the Loire is the marker between these kind of two rival zones of influence. South, the Dauphin, Charles Seventh, as he legally is, that's where he essentially still can draw on support. But north of the Loire, northern France is effectively now an Anglo-Bugandian condominium. Right.
他没有王者之气。他身体上并不出众，看过《黑爵士》第一季的人，他看起来有点像那样。更重要的是，他生活在一个可怕罪行的阴影下，那个臭名昭著的罪行，就是在1419年的和平峰会上谋杀了勃艮第公爵“无畏的约翰”，他曾是法国最有权势的贵族。他的领地不仅在法国东部，也在低地国家。正是这次谋杀促使“无畏的约翰”的儿子菲利普（绰号“好人”）与英格兰人结盟。正如你所说，卢瓦尔河是这两个敌对势力范围之间的分界线。南部，王太子查理七世（法律上的称呼），那是他基本上还能获得支持的地方。但卢瓦尔河以北，法国北部现在实际上是一个英格兰-勃艮第的共管区。没错。
So one other important points about the Dauphin, though. The Dauphan hasn't been crowned, has he? No. So tradition holds that French kings should be crowned in the cathedral in Harn. But Rance is in English territory, and until he can get to Houss and be crowned, people will not accept him as the rifle king of France. That's about right, isn't it? Correct. And this is a big problem to which Joan has a solution.
关于王太子，还有一点很重要。王太子还没有加冕，对吧？没有。所以传统认为法国国王应该在兰斯的教堂加冕。但兰斯在英格兰人的领土内，在他能到达兰斯并加冕之前，人们不会接受他是法国的合法国王。这大概是对的，不是吗？正确。这是一个大问题，而贞德有一个解决方案。
And she wants to meet the Dauphin so that she can present this solution to him. Right. And Charles at this point is in a great castle called Chino, which is south of Loire, not far. It's about 20 miles from Fierbois, where the shrine of St. Catherine is. And when he receives the letter from this illiterate peasant girl, he says, okay, fine, I will meet you. Despite the fact that plenty of his advisors are advising against it, saying, you know, what if she's a crank, what if she's a fraud, you know, what if she's worse, what if she's a sorceress? Because the news has come that this girl is dressed as a man, and this is strictly against biblical injunctions. to people who are worried about the possibility that Joan might be a sorceress,
她想见王太子，以便向他提出这个解决方案。没错。查理此时正身处卢瓦尔河南岸一座叫希农（Chinon）的大城堡里，离菲耶布瓦（圣凯瑟琳圣地所在处）不远，大约20英里。当他收到这封来自文盲农家少女的信时，他说，好吧，没问题，我会见你。尽管他的许多顾问都建议不要这样做，说，你知道，如果她是个疯子怎么办，如果她是个骗子怎么办，你知道，如果她更糟，如果她是个女巫怎么办？因为有消息传来，这个女孩穿着男装，这严格违反了圣经的禁令。对于那些担心贞德可能是女巫的人来说，
the fact that she's wearing male clothing is a kind of warning sign. But Charles overrules this advice and agrees that, yeah, I will see this extraordinary person. And part of this presumably is because he's really up against it. He has nothing to lose. If Ornale falls, this is a disaster for him. The English will pour across the river Loire into the south. So there's that element to it. But also, am I not right in thinking that there are people at his court, not least his mother-in-law, who we talked about last time, who's called Yorland, who is a very impressive woman, who are very keen on Joan, who think that Joan might actually be sent from God.
她穿着男装的事实是一种警告信号。但查理否决了这些建议，并同意，是的，我会见见这个非凡的人。这其中一部分原因大概是因为他真的走投无路了。他没什么可失去的。如果奥尔良陷落，对他来说就是一场灾难。英格兰人将涌过卢瓦尔河进入南部。所以这其中有这个因素。但我也没说错吧，他的宫廷里有人，尤其是他的岳母，我们上次谈到过，叫约兰德（Yolande），她是一位非常令人印象深刻的女性，他们非常看好贞德，认为贞德可能真的是上帝派来的。
Yeah, so Yolande is, she's the dowager duchess of Anjou, and her son, René vonjou, had his power base in the very region from which Joan is coming. And so I think it's easy to see, we talked about it in the previous episode, how between them, they might have evaluated Joan and decided that she was worth taking a punt on. But why would they have thought that her mission might in any way be plausible? And I think there is an explanation for this, and it's to do with the fact that for decades, even before the arrival of Henry V in France to resume the Hundred Years' War, there had been a swirl of prophecies in France for telling that the kingdom would be redeemed by a virgin sent by God. So back in the dying days of the 14th century, there had been this visionary Marie Davignon who had foretold that an armed maid would emerge to save France in her hour of need.
是的，所以约兰德是安茹的太后公爵夫人，她的儿子勒内·德·安茹（René of Anjou）的权力基地就在贞德来的那个地区。所以我认为很容易看出，我们在上一集中谈到过，他们之间是如何评估贞德并决定值得在她身上赌一把的。但为什么他们会认为她的使命在任何方面都是可信的呢？我认为对此有一个解释，这与这样一个事实有关：几十年来，甚至在亨利五世来到法国重启百年战争之前，法国就一直流传着各种预言，预示着王国将由上帝派遣的一位贞女来拯救。早在14世纪末，就有一位有远见的玛丽·达维尼翁（Marie Davignon）预言，一位武装的圣女将在法国危难时刻出现拯救法国。
And there were other prophecies too, and these were cited by Christine de Pizain, who we mentioned in the previous episode, this poet, who wrote this kind of this great eulogy to Joan. And in that poem, Christine listed some of the prophecies. So to quote her, over 500 years ago, her coming was foreseen by Merlin the Sybil and Bede. They wrote of her as someone who would put an end to Francis Trouples, prophesied she would carry a banner in the French wars, and described all she would achieve. So that too, I think, is part of the context. But I think above all, ultimately what enables Joan to secure her meeting with the Dofair is her own energy, her own career. So she has what Marina Warner in her wonderful book on Joan of Art sums up as an astonishing ability to compel credence.
还有其他的预言，这些预言被我们在上一集中提到的克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑（Christine de Pizan）引用过，这位诗人写了这篇对贞德的伟大颂词。在那首诗中，克里斯蒂娜列举了一些预言。引用她的话，500多年前，她的到来就被梅林、西比尔和比德预见到了。他们写道，她将结束法国的苦难，预言她将在法国战争中举起旗帜，并描述了她将取得的一切成就。所以，我认为这也是背景的一部分。但我认为最重要的是，最终使贞德能够获得与王太子会面的机会的是她自己的能量，她自己的信念。所以她拥有玛丽娜·华纳（Marina Warner）在她那本关于圣女贞德的精彩著作中所总结的“一种令人惊叹的、令人信服的能力”。
Somehow, Joan has a genius for making people believe the most extraordinary things. And it had won over her feudal overlord, say René of Anjou and the Duke of Lorraine as well. It had won over Yolande, who's a very kind of hard-boiled, sensible woman. And in due course, when she comes to meet the Dauphin, it wins over the Dauphan as well. So they meet in the Great Hall, the audience chamber, at Xenon. And the Dauphin kicks off, doesn't he, by asking Joan her name. And she says, I'm called Jean Lapucel. And then comes the great bombshell.
不知何故，贞德有一种让人们相信最非凡事情的天赋。它赢得了她的封建领主，比如安茹的勒内和洛林公爵的支持。它赢得了约兰德的支持，她是一个非常精明、理智的女人。而且在适当的时候，当她去见王太子时，它也赢得了王太子的支持。所以他们在希农的大厅，即觐见厅里见面。王太子开口了，不是吗？他问贞德的名字。她说，我叫让娜·拉·普塞尔。然后就是那个重磅炸弹。
Yeah. So Joan goes on. The King of Heaven has commanded that through me you were to be consecrated and crowned in the city of Rass. On behalf of our Lord God, I tell you that you are the. true heir of France. And then again, she gives the don't for her promise, not just that she's going to save or Leon, but that she is going to secure for him the consecration that he desperately craves, that he desperately needs if he is going to be accepted by the mass of French people as the legitimate king. And so she says to him again, God has sent me to take you to rats.
是的。所以贞德继续说。天国之王命令，通过我，你将在兰斯城被祝圣和加冕。我以我们的主上帝的名义告诉你，你是法国真正的继承人。然后，她再次给了王太子承诺，不仅是她要拯救奥尔良，而且她要为他争取到他迫切渴望的祝圣，如果他想被广大法国人民接受为合法国王，他就迫切需要这个。所以她再次对他说，上帝派我来带你去兰斯。
Well, this doesn't seem terribly difficult to explain. I mean, she's basically just telling him what he wants to hear. And in an age when people, you know, are interested in prophecies and saints and stuff like that to have this girl who seems a bit weird turning up and saying, I'm sent by God and, you know, I know everything's going to work out right. I mean, of course he's going to love that, right? Well, he is, but I mean, again, he's not stupid either. He's a very smart guy. He needs to be on his guard. You know, she's come from the region where the Burgundians are very rife. What if she has been sent as a Burgundian agent? So the fact that he is kind of prepared to take a punt on her, I think is tribute to certainly
嗯，这似乎并不难解释。我的意思是，她基本上只是在告诉他他想听的话。在一个人们对预言、圣徒之类的事情感兴趣的时代，有这样一个看起来有点古怪的女孩出现并说，我是上帝派来的，而且，你知道，我知道一切都会好起来的。我的意思是，他当然会喜欢这样，对吧？嗯，他是，但我的意思是，同样，他也不傻。他是一个非常聪明的人。他需要保持警惕。你知道，她来自勃艮第人非常猖獗的地区。如果她是作为勃艮第的代理人被派来的怎么办？所以他愿意在她身上赌一把，我认为这确实归功于贞德的劝说能力。
Joan's powers of persuasion. And it's not just the Dauphin who is persuaded. There is also another guy who is massively smitten by Joan. And this is a guy who also is desperate to believe that God might be sending a virgin savior to redeem France. And this is, again, a guy we met in the previous episode, and he is the Duke of Alonso, Jean. And by now, this guy is 20. So his father had died at Agincourt. He'd been captured in 1424. The Duke of Bedford, the English regent, had appropriated all his lands.
而且不仅仅是王太子被说服了。还有另一个人也被贞德深深吸引。这个人也迫切地相信上帝可能会派遣一位贞女救世主来拯救法国。这就是我们上一集遇到的一个人，他是阿朗松公爵让（Jean, Duke of Alençon）。到目前为止，这家伙20岁了。他的父亲在阿金库尔战役中阵亡。他在1424年被俘。英格兰摄政王贝德福德公爵没收了他所有的土地。
The Duke of Alonsohn had had had to kind of mortgage everything to raise his ransom. So basically he's completely skint and he is known at the court as the poorest man in France, even though he is a Duke of the realm. So you can see again why Alonsohn would be desperate to believe in Joan. And in fact, he starts taking his meals with her. He joins her meetings with the Dofair. They become great pals. Right.
阿朗松公爵不得不抵押一切来筹集赎金。所以基本上他完全破产了，尽管他是王国的公爵，但在宫廷里被称为法国最穷的人。所以你可以再次看出为什么阿朗松会迫切地相信贞德。事实上，他开始和她一起吃饭。他加入了她与王太子的会议。他们成了好朋友。没错。
And he, too, he can sense this sort of conviction in her, this intensity. It's this intensity, actually, that will make her a military leader, right? That she will carry into battle. And I think that's a reason why Alonso and perhaps the Dofant also believe in her, is that they sense that this sense of conviction is something that will inspire their men. and the French armies at this point are demoralized. They have zero morale. So perhaps this girl with her absolute sense of conviction, perhaps that's just what they need.
而且他也能感觉到她身上那种信念，那种强度。实际上，正是这种强度将使她成为一名军事领袖，对吧？她将把这种强度带入战场。我认为这就是为什么阿朗松，也许还有王太子也相信她的原因，是因为他们感觉到这种信念感是能够激励他们士兵的东西。而法国军队此时士气低落。他们毫无士气。所以也许这个带着绝对信念感的女孩，正是他们所需要的。
And the fact that she is a girl, I mean, as we said in the last episode, we did a previous episode about Catherine of Siena, this sort of mystical figure who claimed to have married Christ. The fact that she's a woman, you know, that doesn't make her implausible as a messenger from God. In fact, it enhances it, right? because women have a special place in the, you know, a unique place in the medieval Christian sense of the world. Women obviously can't be priests, but there is a sense that perhaps that gives them a kind of a more intimate relationship with God, that God will sometimes bypass the structure of the church and speak directly to women in a way that he tends not to do to men. Yeah.
而且她是一个女孩的事实，我的意思是，正如我们在上一集中所说，我们做过一期关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳的节目，这个声称嫁给了基督的神秘人物。她是一个女人的事实，这并没有让她作为上帝的信使显得不可信。事实上，它增强了这一点，对吧？因为女性在中世纪基督教的世界观中有着特殊的地位，一个独特的地位。女性显然不能成为牧师，但有一种感觉，也许这给了她们一种与上帝更亲密的关系，上帝有时会绕过教会的结构，直接与女性对话，而他往往不会以这种方式与男性对话。是的。
And Joan, as you said, is absolutely not the first female visionary. to be granted interviews with the powerful and the mighty on the basis of their claim that they have been spoken to by the saints and by God. So Catherine of Siena is exactly such a woman because she had ended up a counsellor and advisor to popes. It was Catherine of Siena who had persuaded the Pope in Avignon to move back to Rome. So it is possible for women who claim a kind of direct access to God to play a striking role in the affairs of Christendom.
而且贞德，正如你所说，绝对不是第一个获得与权贵会面机会的女性预言家，其依据是她们声称自己与圣徒和上帝对话过。所以锡耶纳的凯瑟琳正是这样一位女性，因为她最终成为了教皇的顾问。正是锡耶纳的凯瑟琳说服了阿维尼翁的教皇搬回罗马。所以，声称能够直接接触上帝的女性在基督教事务中发挥显著作用是可能的。
But against that, to repeat, there is an enormous risk in relying on such people. Because what if Joan is a fraud? What if she's been set up by the Burgundians? What if she's delusional? And even if her voices are real, what if they are not from God? What if they are from hell? Yeah. So the first thing to test, I suppose, is whether or not she is who she claims to be.
但反过来说，重申一下，依赖这样的人有巨大的风险。因为如果贞德是个骗子怎么办？如果她是勃艮第人设下的圈套怎么办？如果她有妄想症怎么办？即使她的声音是真的，如果它们不是来自上帝怎么办？如果它们来自地狱怎么办？是的。所以我想首先要测试的是她是否是她所声称的那个人。
So, for example, is she a pucelle, she a maid? So they actually get two women at court, don't they, to examine her and to see whether or not she is, in fact, a virgin. And they say, she is, so that's good news. That is good news. So they've checked out her physical condition, and now they have to check out her kind of moral and spiritual condition. This is called the Discretio-Spiritium.
例如，她是“普塞尔”（Pucelle），她是处女吗？所以他们实际上在宫廷里找了两个女人来检查她，看看她是否真的是处女。她们说，她是，所以这是个好消息。这是个好消息。所以他们检查了她的身体状况，现在他们必须检查她的道德和精神状况。这被称为“辨别神灵”（Discretio Spirituum）。
And they send her off, basically, they send her off for a Viver, PhD Viver. They do. Well, it's kind of like a debrief. I guess. So she sent to Poitiers, not far from Chignot. And in Poitiers, there are all kinds of scholars and doctors from the University of Paris, which has always been the kind of the leading center of theology in Christendom. But lots of these scholars are refugees from the English. And so Poitiers is their kind of base. And among the scholars and doctors there and the prelates is the Archbishop of Rass, who is Charles's chancellor. And so he,
他们基本上把她送去进行了一次“博士论文答辩”。他们确实这样做了。嗯，这有点像汇报。我想。所以她被送到离希农不远的普瓦捷。在普瓦捷，有来自巴黎大学的各种学者和医生，巴黎大学一直是基督教世界领先的神学中心。但这些学者中有许多是来自英格兰人的难民。所以普瓦捷是他们的基地。在当地的学者、医生和高级教士中，有兰斯大主教，他是查理的宰相。所以他，
puts himself at the head of the investigation into Joan. And they more than anyone, even more than the king, is alert to the risks. So to quote Helen Castor, a friend of the show, author of a wonderful book on Joan of Arc. Female visionaries in the church's recent history had experienced their revelations when they were already under the care of a spiritual advisor. So this was true of Catherine of Siena, a confessor perhaps, who could testify to their morals and the nature of their claims. Joan, by contrast, had appeared alone apart from her escort of armed men. And rather than simply conveying a message from heaven, she, a teenage girl, wanted to lead the king's troops into battle. And so this does make her exceptional.
把自己放在了对贞德调查的首位。他们比任何人都更清楚风险，甚至比国王更清楚。引用海伦·卡斯托（Helen Castor）的话，她是节目的朋友，也是一本关于圣女贞德的精彩著作的作者：教会近代史上的女性预言家在她们的启示发生时，已经处于一位精神导师的照顾之下。锡耶纳的凯瑟琳就是如此，也许有一位忏悔神父可以证明她们的道德和她们主张的性质。相比之下，贞德除了她的武装护卫外，是独自出现的。而且她不是简单地传达来自天堂的信息，她，一个十几岁的女孩，想要带领国王的军队投入战斗。所以这确实使她与众不同。
Nothing really like Joan has been seen before. Right. To repeat, she's wearing male clothes and that she absolutely insists on wearing them. And then on top of that, there's the styling of these male clothes. They're not drab. Joan clearly is a bit of a fashionista. She loves exactly the kind of expensive male clothing that moralists at the time are very down on. So this also is a cause of anxiety. But the people in Poitiers say, no, she's okay. She has conversed with everyone publicly and privately, but no evil is found in her. Only goodness, humility, virginity, piety, integrity and simplicity. I have to say, they're making it sound absolutely awful. and her clothing they say that's fine too because actually Christ has kind of superseded Deuteronomy
以前真的没见过像贞德这样的人。没错。重申一下，她穿着男装，而且她绝对坚持要穿。除此之外，还有这些男装的款式。它们并不单调。贞德显然有点时尚感。她喜欢当时道德家们非常反对的那种昂贵的男装。所以这也是焦虑的原因。但普瓦捷的人说，不，她没问题。她公开和私下与每个人交谈过，但没有发现她身上有任何邪恶。只有善良、谦逊、贞洁、虔诚、正直和纯朴。我不得不说，他们让这听起来非常糟糕。至于她的服装，他们说那也没问题，因为实际上基督已经取代了《申命记》，
and actually Deuteronomy doesn't really apply to a woman who's been sent by God to lead men in war to recapture aure Leon from the English so it's kind of fine yeah because basically the scholars too want to believe in it you know they're desperate to see the English thrown out and also of course they know what the dofam wants and so essentially they're serving it up to him So this is their verdict, which they send back to the Dauphan. The king should not prevent Joan from going to Aureon with his soldiers, but should have her escorted there honorably placing his faith in God. So essentially they're saying, you know, take a punt on it.
而且实际上《申命记》并不真正适用于一个被上帝派遣来领导男人作战以从英格兰人手中夺回奥尔良的女人，所以这没问题。是的，因为基本上学者们也想相信这一点，你知道，他们迫切希望看到英格兰人被赶走，而且当然他们知道王太子想要什么，所以本质上他们是在迎合他。所以这就是他们的裁决，他们把它送回给王太子。国王不应阻止贞德带着他的士兵前往奥尔良，而应让她光荣地护送前往，将他的信仰寄托于上帝。所以本质上他们是在说，你知道，赌一把吧。
Let's see what happens. And this is the point when Joan dictates the letter that we began with to the English, basically an ultimatum. I'm on my way. You better watch out. Yeah. Although she doesn't at this point send it. She will send it later on.
看看会发生什么。这就是贞德向英格兰人口述我们开头提到的那封信的时候，基本上是一份最后通牒。我来了。你们最好小心点。是的。虽然她此时并没有把它发出去。她稍后会发出去。
But it's there waiting to go. And so then from Poitiers, she, rejoins the Dauphin, who has moved from Chignon to Tor, Tor, Tor is on the Loire, and here, in the full gaze of the court and therefore France, the seal is set on her status as the potential redeemer of France, and this happens in three ways. First of all, she submits to an intimate inspection, this time by Yolande. There's a lot of inspections. Then there's a kind of mad pantomime at court where Joan arrives and she gets directed to a captain and told this is the dofair. And then to someone who has just returned from Aure and told, well,
但它就在那里等着发出。于是从普瓦捷出发，她与王太子会合，王太子已经从希农搬到了图尔（Tours），图尔在卢瓦尔河上，在这里，在宫廷乃至整个法国的注视下，她作为法国潜在救世主的地位得到了确认，这通过三种方式实现。首先，她接受了亲密的检查，这次是由约兰德进行的。检查太多了。然后宫廷里上演了一场疯狂的哑剧，贞德到达，她被引向一位队长，并被告知这就是王太子。然后又被引向一个刚从奥尔良回来的人，并被告知，嗯，
this is the dofair. And she says, oh, no, no, no, it's not. And she goes up to the real dofair. But hold on. She's met the dofair, hasn't she? She has. So it's a pantomime. It's staged. It's clearly designed to illustrate both the inherent regality of the dofair and, you know, the ability of Joan to fathom it. That's the maddest thing in this story so far. An identity parade when she's already met him. No, it's not mad because it's a kind of pageant. It's a display making public to the court, the role that both the King and Joan are going to play. And then something very weird and mysterious does happen, which is not normal at all.
这就是王太子。她说，哦，不，不，不，不是。然后她走向真正的王太子。等等。她见过王太子，不是吗？她见过。所以这是一场哑剧。它是精心策划的。它显然旨在说明王太子的内在尊贵和贞德洞察它的能力。这是这个故事到目前为止最疯狂的事情。当她已经见过他时，还要进行身份辨认？不，这不疯狂，因为它是一种庆典。这是一种展示，向宫廷公开国王和贞德将要扮演的角色。然后发生了一件非常奇怪和神秘的事情，这根本不正常。
He asks Joan for a sign, convince me, reassure me that you have indeed come from God. And Joan gives it to him. what this sign was remains veiled. It's not publicized. And in due course, Joan will be asked about it at her trial and she will talk about it. But we will come to that later on. Oh, my word. That's tantalizing. Isn't that exciting? It is tantalizing. It's a complex issue. But I think it's clear that the sign is accepted by the Dauphin. The green light is given. Joan is ready to go to war. So it's now late April, and as she rides off, she is a magnificent sight. So she is wearing a full suit of white armour that has been handmade for her by the king's own armourer.
他向贞德要一个标志，说服我，让我确信你确实是上帝派来的。贞德给了他。这个标志是什么仍然是个谜。它没有被公开。在适当的时候，贞德会在她的审判中被问及此事，她会谈论它。但我们稍后会谈到这一点。天哪。这太诱人了。这不令人兴奋吗？这确实很诱人。这是一个复杂的问题。但我认为很明显，这个标志被王太子接受了。绿灯亮了。贞德准备好去打仗了。所以现在是四月下旬，当她骑马离开时，她是一个壮观的景象。所以她穿着一套白色的全身盔甲，这是国王自己的盔甲匠为她手工制作的。
She has a new sword, which had been found behind the altar of the church at Fierbois, and which Joan later would say that her voices had said would be found there. So she had then sent messengers, and they had discovered this sword. and the sword is very mysterious. It's covered with rust, which magically falls away as soon as it's touched, and it reveals five crosses along the blade, and on the edge are inscribed the words Jesus and Maria. This, of course, is absolutely part of medieval romance. It's very Lord of the Rings. Yeah. The sword that was broken kind of thing. A great hero has to have a magical sword, and Joe now has a magical sword. And she's got a very nice banner,
她有一把新剑，是在菲耶布瓦教堂的祭坛后面发现的，贞德后来会说她的声音曾说会在那里找到它。所以她当时派了信使，他们发现了这把剑。这把剑非常神秘。它覆盖着铁锈，一触碰就神奇地脱落了，露出了刀刃上的五个十字架，边缘刻着“耶稣和玛丽亚”的字样。这当然完全是中世纪浪漫史的一部分。非常像《指环王》。是的。破碎的剑之类的东西。伟大的英雄必须有一把神奇的剑，而贞德现在有一把神奇的剑。她还有一面非常漂亮的旗帜，
well. People are often like a kind of magic banner, don't they? I mean, you say very nice. This is a magnificent banner. So it's made out of white silk. It's covered in golden fleur-de-Lee. Again, the words Jesusu and Maria are stitched into it, and they appear alongside an image of Christ flanked by two angels. So it's a really splendid sight. She's on a black horse, which is a gift from the Duke of Alonsoor, who absolutely loves her. We've said that. He'd seen her practicing in the lists that Sheenor had been so impressed that he gave her the best charger that he had in his stables. And again, I mean, how Joan had made herself so proficient at horsemanship is a kind of puzzle. It's a, it's a mystery. And she is at the head of
嗯。人们通常喜欢某种魔法旗帜，不是吗？我的意思是，你说非常漂亮。这是一面壮观的旗帜。它是由白色丝绸制成的。上面覆盖着金色的鸢尾花。同样，“耶稣和玛丽亚”的字样缝在上面，它们出现在基督两侧有两个天使的图像旁边。所以这是一个非常壮观的景象。她骑着一匹黑马，这是阿朗松公爵送的礼物，他绝对爱她。我们说过。他在希农看过她练习，印象非常深刻，以至于他把马厩里最好的战马给了她。而且，我的意思是，贞德是如何让自己变得如此精通骑术的，这是一个谜。这是一个谜。她现在率领着
an entire military retinue now. And this is led by the man who will serve her as her squire, a guy who's a very experienced soldier called Jean Dolan. And he's basically there not just to serve her, but to look after her and protect her to make sure she doesn't get captured. What's going on in Aulian? Well, this has been happening because the Aulian has been besieged all this time, so presumably the people there are getting increasingly desperate. Well, the news from Aureoleon is very grim. The garrison is depleted.
整个军事随从。这由将担任她侍从的人领导，一个非常有经验的士兵，名叫让·多隆（Jean d'Aulon）。他基本上在那里不仅是为了服务她，而且是为了照顾她并保护她，确保她不会被俘虏。奥尔良发生了什么？嗯，这一直在发生，因为奥尔良一直被围困，所以大概那里的人越来越绝望了。嗯，来自奥尔良的消息非常严峻。驻军被削减了。
The supplies are running out, both ammunition and food, and people are starting to starve. And so Jones' mission is to ride with a convoy of some 3,000 men that the Dauphin has scrabbled together. He's found ammunition. He's found food. He's put them in wagons. He's got a kind of herd of cattle. And Joni's going to accompany this train and hopefully get to Orleans and relieve the siege in that way. And so they set off. She's taking her role as God's messenger very seriously. So all prostitutes have been banished. There are priests singing hymns at the head of the convoy. Soldiers who are marching are urged to offer confession daily. And I can see from your face, Dominic, that you were thinking this is not the way to build Ben's morale.
补给快用完了，弹药和食物都是，人们开始挨饿。所以贞德的使命是带着王太子拼凑起来的约3000人的车队出发。他找到了弹药。他找到了食物。他把它们装进马车。他有一群牛。贞德将陪同这支队伍，并希望到达奥尔良，以这种方式解除围困。于是他们出发了。她非常认真地对待她作为上帝信使的角色。所以所有的妓女都被驱逐了。车队前面有牧师在唱赞美诗。行军的士兵被敦促每天忏悔。我从你的脸上可以看出，多米尼克，你在想这不是激励士兵士气的方法。
No. But actually, it seems that it does. It seems to have inspired the men. And as they ride, their morale is palpably higher. Okay. Well, I'm glad I'm not in that way. That's what I'll say. Well, you know, horses for courses, Dominic.
不。但实际上，它似乎确实做到了。它似乎激励了士兵。当他们骑行时，他们的士气明显更高了。好吧。好吧，我很高兴我不在那条路上。这就是我要说的。嗯，你知道，萝卜青菜，各有所爱，多米尼克。
Yeah, of course. You know, this is the 15th century. They approach Aureon and they reach it on the evening of the 28th of April. But when they get there and Joan can see Orleans, for the first time. She makes a terrible discovery because she and her fellow warriors and the wagon train are on the south side of the Loire and O'Leon is on the north side of the Loire. And that is where the vast majority of the English are as well. And Joan feels that she has come to attack the English. So what's she doing on the wrong side of the river? How has this
是的，当然。你知道，这是15世纪。他们接近奥尔良，并在4月28日晚上到达。但当他们到达那里，贞德第一次看到奥尔良时。她发现了一个可怕的事实，因为她和她的战士同伴以及马车队都在卢瓦尔河南岸，而奥尔良在卢瓦尔河北岸。而绝大多数英格兰人也在那里。贞德觉得她是来攻击英格兰人的。那么她在河的错误一边在做什么？这怎么
been allowed to happen? Has she been deliberately deceived by the French captains? what a cliffhanger. I can't. I can't contain myself. I'm so excited. Come back after the break and we'll find out what's gone wrong and why she's on the wrong side of that river. Every family has a story. Now you can discover the chapters you've never read at an amazing low price. With an ancestry membership, you can start building your family tree and easily search and add the historical records you uncover. Memberships are now at their lowest price of the year. With billions of new records, powerful features and intuitive search tools, it's easier and faster than ever to get Get ready to say, look what I found. Visit Ancestry.ca slash New Year for more details. Terms apply.
被允许发生？她是被法国队长们故意欺骗了吗？真是个悬念。我不能。我无法控制自己。我太兴奋了。休息后回来，我们会发现出了什么问题，以及为什么她在河的错误一边。每个家庭都有一个故事。现在，您可以以惊人的低价发现您从未读过的篇章。有了Ancestry会员资格，您可以开始建立您的家谱，并轻松搜索和添加您发现的历史记录。会员资格现在处于一年中的最低价格。拥有数十亿条新记录、强大的功能和直观的搜索工具，比以往任何时候都更容易、更快地准备好说，看我发现了什么。访问Ancestry.ca/NewYear了解更多详情。条款适用。
Welcome back to the Restus History. Unbelievable tension. Of course, it's been mounting during the break, while those of you who are not members of the Restis History Club have been listening to the adverts. Now, while you've been listening to the adverts, Joan of Arc has been steaming with rage. It's the evening of the 28th of April, 1429. She's on the bank of the Loire, which is broader than it is now, fast-flowing river. On the other side, she can see Aureon and the English. She can see the citadel, the spires of the churches, the city walls. So Tom, she can also see the ruins of a bridge, can't she?
欢迎回到《Rest is History》。难以置信的紧张感。当然，在休息期间，这种紧张感一直在增加，而那些不是《Rest is History》俱乐部成员的人一直在听广告。现在，当你们听广告的时候，圣女贞德一直在愤怒中沸腾。那是1429年4月28日的晚上。她在卢瓦尔河岸边，这条河比现在更宽，水流湍急。在另一边，她可以看到奥尔良和英格兰人。她可以看到城堡、教堂的尖顶、城墙。所以汤姆，她也能看到一座桥的废墟，不是吗？
And this is going to play a very important part in this story. Yeah. So the archers have been demolished. So you've just got the kind of the pillars of the bridge. And this had connected the city to an Augustinian priory on the side. South Bank and also to a great fortress called Le Tourelle, which directly commanded the approaches, the roads from the south, leading over the bridge into the city of Orleans. And the defenders of Orleans had demolished it for obvious reasons in the early days of the siege
这将在故事中发挥非常重要的作用。是的。所以拱门已经被拆除了。所以你只剩下桥的支柱了。这曾将城市与南岸的一座奥古斯丁修道院连接起来，也连接到一座名为“图雷尔”（Les Tourelles）的大型堡垒，它直接指挥着从南面通往奥尔良市的道路。奥尔良的守军在围攻初期出于显而易见的原因拆除了它，
because the English had gathered on the South Bank and had captured the citadel of Leite Relle and the Priory. and Létreuille is now the major English stronghold on the South Bank. So directly facing O'Leon. It's under the command of a guy called Sir William Glastale, who even though he is a knight, had begun his career as an archer, very proficient and formidable warrior. And he has turned Léterrelle into a kind of massive platform for artillery.
因为英格兰人聚集在南岸，并占领了图雷尔城堡和修道院。而图雷尔现在是英格兰人在南岸的主要据点。所以直接面对奥尔良。它由一个叫威廉·格拉斯代尔（Sir William Glasdale）爵士的人指挥，他虽然是一名骑士，但职业生涯始于弓箭手，是一位非常精通且令人生畏的战士。他已经把图雷尔变成了一个巨大的炮兵平台。
And this artillery, it's firing across the Loire, It's battering the walls of Aureon on the North Bank. And Glasdale is able to hurl abuse at the defenders of Aureon, kind of threatening them with, you know, he's going to slaughter the lot of them when he captures the city. He's a notorious figure. So there's Glasgow in Létrell, and it's a significant target, but Joan isn't really interested in it because she knows that the real action is on the north side. That's where the English have focused most of their efforts. On the north side, they've got three fortresses along the length of the Loire, kind of blocking off attempts to relieve the city by the river.
这些火炮，它在卢瓦尔河上开火，它正在轰击北岸奥尔良的城墙。格拉斯代尔能够向奥尔良的守军辱骂，威胁他们，你知道，他要在占领城市时屠杀他们所有人。他是一个臭名昭著的人物。所以格拉斯代尔在图雷尔，这是一个重要的目标，但贞德对它并不真正感兴趣，因为她知道真正的行动是在北岸。那是英格兰人集中大部分努力的地方。在北岸，他们在卢瓦尔河沿岸有三座堡垒，阻挡了通过河流解救城市的尝试。
And they've also got a great screen of fortresses on the western side of the city that runs from Loire up to a great forest north of Aulior. So that basically is kind of blocking off access from there. Now, on the eastern side of Aure, things are open. So that is an opportunity, perhaps, for the French. And so this is what they decide that they will do. do. They decide that they will go up river, maybe six miles north of Aureon, and there they will make a crossing, and they will then come back, and they will try and get into Aureon that way,
他们还在城市西侧有一道巨大的堡垒屏障，从卢瓦尔河一直延伸到奥尔良北部的森林。所以这基本上阻挡了从那里的进入。现在，在奥尔良东侧，情况是开放的。所以这也许是法国人的一个机会。所以这就是他们决定要做的。他们决定向上游走，也许在奥尔良以北六英里处，在那里他们将过河，然后他们会回来，并尝试以那种方式进入奥尔良，
because there aren't that many English siegeworks blocking them. And the guy who comes up with this strategy is the guy who has been in command in Aure and who has been rowed over to meet Joan and the relief force. And this is a very, very impressive man. He is called Jean. And he's And he is also more impressively known as the bastard of O'Leon. And he's called this because he's the half-brother, the illegitimate half-brother, of the Duke of O'Neon, who's in captivity in England, isn't he? Yes. And this guy, the bastard, he's 27.
因为没有那么多英格兰人的围攻工事阻挡他们。而提出这个策略的人是那个一直在奥尔良指挥，并被划船过来迎接贞德和救援部队的人。这是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻的人。他叫让（Jean）。他也被更令人印象深刻地称为“奥尔良的私生子”（Bastard of Orleans）。他被称为这个，因为他是奥尔良公爵的同父异母的私生兄弟，公爵现在被囚禁在英格兰，不是吗？是的。而这个家伙，私生子，他27岁。
He's very formidable. He's a serious person. He's a very experienced commander. He's the Doverand's cousin. And actually, one reason for his prominence is that he's the last man standing of the House of O'Neon, who's in a position to fight for. the city of Orleans. Yeah, and there's an incredible painting of him. People could look him up.
他非常令人生畏。他是一个严肃的人。他是一位经验丰富的指挥官。他是奥尔良公爵的堂弟。事实上，他之所以声名显赫，原因之一就是他是奥尔良家族中最后一位有能力为奥尔良城而战的人。是的，还有一幅关于他的绝妙画像。人们可以去查查他。
I mean, it's such a realistic portrait. You look at it and you can absolutely imagine what he's like, not the kind of person that you, I think, would want to get into an argument with, but also clearly very smart. But Joan has to be said, is not impressed. Despite the fact that the bastard of Aulian is the cousin of the king himself, She roundly bollocks him. Was it on your advice, she demands that I've been brought here on this side of the river
我的意思是，这幅肖像画得太逼真了。你看着它，绝对能想象出他是什么样的人，我想你肯定不想和他争论，但他显然也非常聪明。但必须说，贞德并没有被打动。尽管奥尔良私生子是国王本人的堂弟，但她还是严厉地斥责了他。她质问道，是不是听了你的建议，我才被带到河的这一边，
instead of going directly against Talbot and the English. And John Talbot is the most feared of all the English commanders. And the bastard of all you asked, you know, he says, yeah, sorry. You know, it's absolutely my decision. And Joan is very angry. She's very hurt. She says, I have brought you the best reinforcement that any soldier or city ever had the support of the king of heaven.
而不是直接去对抗塔尔博特和英国人。约翰·塔尔博特是所有英国指挥官中最令人恐惧的。而奥尔良私生子，你知道，他说，是的，抱歉。你知道，这绝对是我的决定。贞德非常生气。她感到非常受伤。她说，我给你带来了任何士兵或城市所能拥有的最好的增援——来自天国之王的支援。
And I think, Dominic, that at this point you can imagine. imagine the bastard of Olleyr pulling the kind of face that you even now are pulling. Not wrong. But they have another councillor war the next morning, don't they? And once again, she starts ranting and raving about how she wants to go on to the attack straight away. She's very bas-ball about it. You know, let's just attack.
我想，多米尼克，此时你可以想象一下。想象一下奥尔良私生子露出了你现在脸上那种表情。没错。但他们第二天早上又开了一次战争会议，不是吗？她又一次开始喋喋不休地嚷嚷着她想立刻发起进攻。她对此非常直率。你知道，我们直接进攻吧。
But again, she's ignored because the priority is to get the supplies across to the city. And so the bastards's plan that they will go up river, this is now, everyone, apart from Joan, says, yes, this is a great idea. And so that's what they do. And so the plan is that they will go there and they will load the supplies onto barges and then the barges will go back and take the food to Orlyon. But when they get there, absolute disaster, the current is obviously against the barges, but so too is the wind, which is very, very strong, almost gale force.
但她再次被忽视了，因为当务之急是把补给运进城里。于是私生子的计划是他们沿河而上，现在除了贞德，每个人都说，这真是个好主意。于是他们就这么做了。计划是他们去那里，把补给装上驳船，然后驳船再返回，把食物运到奥尔良。但当他们到达那里时，简直是一场灾难，水流显然对驳船不利，风也是如此，风非常非常大，几乎达到了大风的强度。
And it's preventing the barges from reaching the French supply force. So what does Joan do? She kneels down. She prays to God to change the course of the wind. And Dominic, miraculously, the wind changes. Yeah, that is a miracle. I mean, winds never change otherwise, right? The bastard of Ollion is convinced. And from this point on, he is persuaded that Joan has indeed been sent by God. So the supplies are loaded onto the barges. They're then sent back to O'Leon,
这阻碍了驳船到达法国的补给部队。那么贞德做了什么？她跪了下来。她祈求上帝改变风向。多米尼克，奇迹般地，风向真的变了。是的，那真是个奇迹。我的意思是，风从来不会无缘无故改变，对吧？奥尔良私生子被说服了。从这一刻起，他确信贞德确实是上帝派来的。于是补给被装上驳船。然后它们被送回奥尔良，
and 200 men at arms with Joan now cross the River Loire to the North Bank, but not the rest of the expedition, not the rest of the 3,000 men. They instead turn around and head back to Blois, downriver from Aureon, which is their base. Right. And the reason for this, and again, Joan is upset about this because she had to imagine that these soldiers had been sent to take on the English, but this turns out not to have been the case at all. So again, she's absolutely steaming.
200名武装士兵和贞德现在穿过卢瓦尔河到达北岸，但远征军的其余部分，即剩下的3000人并没有随行。他们反而转身回到了奥尔良下游的布卢瓦，那是他们的基地。没错。原因在于此，贞德对此感到很不高兴，因为她本以为这些士兵是被派来对抗英国人的，但事实证明根本不是这样。所以她再次感到非常愤怒。
However, now she's on the North Bank, she is able to ride back the six miles and get to Aureon because, as we said, there aren't really many English fortresses in the way. So the English have not been able to cut it off completely, so they've left gaps in the east. They haven't got enough men. Yeah, and she's able to just ride straight in, basically, isn't she? Yes. And so she makes a triumphant entry into the city. She's got her page preceding her, carrying her great silken banner. She's flanked on one side by the bastard of Aulior, but also on the other by one of the most formidable of all the French captains, a guy known by the English and indeed by the French as Lair, who is a man of very humble origins.
然而，现在她已经在北岸了，她可以骑马跑回六英里路到达奥尔良，因为正如我们所说，路上并没有太多英国人的堡垒。所以英国人没能完全切断它，他们在东面留下了缺口。他们没有足够的人手。是的，她基本上可以直接骑马进去，不是吗？是的。于是她凯旋进入了城市。她的侍从走在前面，举着她那面巨大的丝绸旗帜。她的一侧是奥尔良私生子，另一侧是法国最令人生畏的队长之一，一个被英国人甚至法国人称为“拉伊尔”的人，他出身非常卑微。
he's lame because he had a spectacular accident when the chimney of a pub fell on his legs. Oh my God. You know, it hasn't stopped him from forging a very impressive reputation for himself. And in fact, his name Lair seems to have come from the Latin Ereidae, the wrath of God, which is the nickname that the English give him. Yeah, like the friend of the show Lopé de Aguirre. Yeah. He's a menacing figure as well.
他是个瘸子，因为有一次酒吧的烟囱倒在他腿上，导致了一场严重的事故。天哪。你知道，这并没有阻止他为自己赢得令人印象深刻的声誉。事实上，他的名字“拉伊尔”似乎来自拉丁语“Ereidae”，意为“上帝的愤怒”，这是英国人给他的绰号。是的，就像节目的朋友洛佩·德·阿吉雷一样。是的。他也是一个威胁性的人物。
And there he is by the side of Joan. Joan, of course, is delighted by the reception she gets. You know, she's being cheered and saluted as the saviour of Orlyor. But she knows that she still has lots to do, chief of which is persuading the bastard of Aulio and La Aere that they should go on the offensive and attack the English. The bastard and Lair say, we can't because we haven't got enough men. We still haven't got enough men. And the people of Aulior seeing Jones' escort how few it is in number, only
他就站在贞德身边。贞德当然对她受到的欢迎感到高兴。你知道，她被欢呼和致敬为奥尔良的救星。但她知道她还有很多事情要做，其中最主要的就是说服奥尔良私生子和拉伊尔，他们应该转守为攻，进攻英国人。私生子和拉伊尔说，我们不能，因为我们人手不够。我们还是人手不够。而奥尔良的人民看到贞德的护卫队人数如此之少，只有
200 men rather than the thousands they've been hoping for. They also, like Joan, are very downcast. And despite their delight at getting food supplies and, you know, extra ammunition, they almost immediately plunge back into a deep despond. And there's a sense that barely hours after Joan has arrived, morale is in a sense even worse than it had been before Joan arrived. And Joan and the Bastard of Orleans respond to this crisis in their own distinctive ways. So, Joan's approach is to send a letter to Talbot and the English commanders. And of course, she had already sent Talbot a letter, that letter, Dominic, that you read out at the beginning of the show.
200人，而不是他们所希望的数千人。他们也像贞德一样，感到非常沮丧。尽管他们很高兴得到了食物补给和额外的弹药，但他们几乎立刻又陷入了深深的绝望。有一种感觉，在贞德到达后仅仅几个小时，士气在某种意义上甚至比贞德到达之前还要糟糕。贞德和奥尔良私生子以各自独特的方式应对这场危机。所以，贞德的方法是给塔尔博特和英国指挥官写一封信。当然，她已经给塔尔博特写过一封信了，多米尼克，就是你在节目开头读的那封信。
Yeah. The Herald who had taken that letter had been held captive by Talbot, which is very poor form. That's not the kind of thing that you should do with Heralds. And so Joan is very angry about this. And she, in the second letter, she demands that he released the herald, that she give up the siege and that he and all the rest of the English retire from Alleyore and go back to England. Taubert, when he gets this letter, says, all right, I'm going to release the herald. But he also sends Joan a message with this herald saying, you are a whore, you should return to herding livestock. If you don't, you are going to be burned as a witch. And Joan, of course, is absolutely outraged by this. And so she climbs up
是的。那个送信的传令官被塔尔博特扣押了，这非常失礼。这不是你应该对待传令官的方式。所以贞德对此非常生气。在第二封信中，她要求他释放传令官，放弃围城，并要求他和所有其他英国人撤出奥尔良，回到英国。塔尔博特收到这封信后说，好吧，我会释放传令官。但他还通过这个传令官给贞德带了一句话，说：你是个妓女，你应该回去放牧牲畜。如果你不这样做，你就会被当作女巫烧死。贞德当然对此感到非常愤怒。于是她爬上
onto the battlements overlooking the Loire, and she shouts out to the English in L'etarelle, the great fortress on the south side, telling them to surrender. And they also reply with insults. And specifically, they say, well, why would we surrender to a whore and her pimps? You are all toast. Right. So that's Joan's approach. Yeah. The bastard of Orleans approach, he decides actually maybe Joan has a point. Maybe there is no point in just trying to kind of string the siege along. Maybe we really do have to stake everything on a single throw. Because if we don't, then the city is going to fall.
俯瞰卢瓦尔河的城墙，向南岸大堡垒里的英国人喊话，叫他们投降。他们也用侮辱的话语回应。具体来说，他们说，好吧，我们为什么要向一个妓女和她的皮条客投降？你们都死定了。没错。这就是贞德的方法。是的。奥尔良私生子的方法是，他决定也许贞德有道理。也许一直拖延围城毫无意义。也许我们真的必须孤注一掷。因为如果我们不这样做，那么城市就会陷落。
And so on the 1st of May, he leaves Aureon and he rides to Blois as fast as he possibly can. And when he gets there, he persuades all the various captains who were gathered there that they need to return with him to Aureon because unless they do, then the city is definitely going to be lost. And this time he decides he's not going to go along the south bank, he's going to go along the north bank, so directly towards the English siege positions where they're strongest. In other words, he basically has adopted Jones' plan. And this plan, of course, because the English siege lines are at their strongest, means that he is probably going to have to fight his way through.
于是5月1日，他以最快的速度离开奥尔良，骑马前往布卢瓦。到达那里后，他劝说所有聚集在那里的队长，他们必须和他一起回到奥尔良，因为除非他们这样做，否则城市肯定会失守。这一次他决定不再走南岸，而是走北岸，直接朝英国人围城阵地最坚固的地方走去。换句话说，他基本上采纳了贞德的计划。当然，由于英国人的围城防线最坚固，这个计划意味着他可能不得不杀出一条血路。
So on the 3rd of May, the bastard leaves blah. He's got another huge train of wagons full of ammunition and food and stuff. and the following day he approaches the English lines on the western flank of Aureon. They're kind of fortresses, siege positions and so on. Simultaneously, as he approaches the siege lines, a squad of 500 horsemen led by Lair and accompanied by Joan with her splendid banner, Sally out from Aureon, to meet them. They are, of course, absolutely expecting that the English will be there and that there will be a battle. But in the event, the English don't try to stop them. The bastard of Ollion and his men are able to pass through the siege lines.
所以5月3日，私生子离开了布卢瓦。他带着另一列装满弹药、食物和物资的庞大车队。第二天，他接近了奥尔良西侧的英国防线。那里有一些堡垒、围城阵地等等。与此同时，当他接近围城防线时，由拉伊尔带领、贞德带着她那面华丽旗帜陪同的500名骑兵小队从奥尔良出击，去迎接他们。他们当然完全预料到英国人会在那里，并且会有一场战斗。但结果，英国人并没有试图阻止他们。奥尔良私生子和他的部下得以穿过围城防线。
They meet up with the horsemen led by Lair and accompanied by Joan. And together, in a mood of absolute triumph, they head to O'Leon, they enter the city, and there they are. They haven't had to fight. And the reason for this is basically because, and we've touched on it before, The English don't have quite enough men to make the investment of Aure absolute. There are about 4,000 of them
他们与拉伊尔带领、贞德陪同的骑兵会合。他们一起，带着绝对胜利的情绪，前往奥尔良，进入了城市，他们就在那里。他们根本不需要战斗。原因基本上是因为，我们之前提到过，英国人没有足够的人手来完全封锁奥尔良。他们大约有4000人，
and these 4,000 men have to occupy a series of fortresses that are scattered all around Aureen, including, of course, Laterall on the South Bank. I have to say, Tom, it's really striking you make this point. So the siege of Aulian, the relief of Aulian is often seen as this sort of miraculous underdog victory against all the odds. But actually, if there's only 4,000 English, I mean, when you think of all the battles who've done on the rest is history, I'm not talking about the World Wars and so on, but I don't
这4000人必须占据散布在奥尔良周围的一系列堡垒，当然也包括南岸的图雷尔。我必须说，汤姆，你提出这一点真的很引人注目。所以奥尔良之围，奥尔良的解围，通常被视为一种奇迹般的以弱胜强的胜利。但实际上，如果只有4000名英国人，我的意思是，当你想到《历史的其余部分》中提到的所有战役时，我不是在谈论世界大战等等，但我不知道，
know, the Great Northern War or something, you know, these numbers are pretty small, aren't they? I mean, by the standards of some wars, this is a skirmish rather than a battle. Not by the standards of the 100 years war. I mean, 4,000 is a really substantial force, and it would certainly be a substantial force in a pitch battle. But Orlyon is a large city. So, there just aren't quite enough. And also there is a kind of a backup force that had been stationed by the English for just such an eventuality, but the messengers don't reach it in time.
大北方战争之类的，这些数字相当小，不是吗？我的意思是，按照某些战争的标准，这与其说是战役，不如说是小规模冲突。但按照百年战争的标准，4000人确实是一支相当强大的力量，在正面交锋中肯定是一支强大的力量。但奥尔良是一座大城市。所以，人手确实不够。而且英国人为了应对这种情况预留了一支后备部队，但信使没能及时赶到。
And so that's a kind of, that's a piece of luck. And the consequence of this is that basically the French numbers now match the English. The French now have about 4,000 men as well. Yeah, and the English are fighting on foreign soil as well, so they've really got it all to do. Well, but also they're scattered in all these fortresses, whereas the French are concentrated in a single person. place. And so this is, you know, this is a key moment. And so now, Joan, when she says to the Bastard of Olio and Lahia, come on, let's have a crack, let's get on with it. They say, yeah, fine, okay, let's. And so that same afternoon that the Bastard of O'Ollion has arrived in
所以这算是一种运气。结果就是法国人的数量现在与英国人相当了。法国人现在也有大约4000人。是的，而且英国人是在外国领土上作战，所以他们确实面临着巨大的挑战。嗯，但他们也分散在所有这些堡垒中，而法国人则集中在一个地方。所以，这是一个关键时刻。现在，当贞德对奥尔良私生子和拉伊尔说，来吧，让我们试一试，让我们开始吧。他们说，好吧，没问题，那就开始吧。于是，就在奥尔良私生子到达的当天下午，
Aure, they decide to attack the softest English target available to them, which is a very isolated fortress east of O'Leon on the North Bank. So basically, there aren't any kind of other English soldiers ready to hand, the garrison in that fortress is on its own. And so the French launched a full-scale attack against this fortress, and it falls after three hours of very hard fighting. The English, you'll be pleased to hear, put up a very good show. Of course they do. And this is Jones' first experience of battle. She doesn't actually fight herself. You know, she never actually draws a sword. She never kills anyone. But she is absolutely in the battle line, brandishing her banner, urging the French on
他们决定攻击他们能找到的最软的英国目标，那是一个位于奥尔良北岸东侧的非常孤立的堡垒。基本上，附近没有其他英国士兵，那个堡垒里的守军是孤立无援的。于是法国人对这个堡垒发动了全面进攻，经过三个小时的激烈战斗，堡垒陷落了。你会很高兴听到，英国人表现得非常出色。他们当然会。这是贞德第一次经历战斗。她自己并没有真正战斗。你知道，她从不拔剑。她从不杀人。但她绝对站在战线上，挥舞着她的旗帜，敦促法国人前进。
and at the end of the when the fortress has been captured blood is flowing she sees this for the first time and so she broods on it that evening I think and the next day she makes yet another call on the English
在堡垒被攻克、鲜血流淌的时候，她第一次看到了这一切，所以那天晚上她一直在沉思，第二天她又一次呼吁英国人
to surrender so again she writes her third letter to them you men of England who have no right to this kingdom of France the king of heaven orders and commands you through me Joan the maid to abandon your strongholds and go back to your own country if not I will make a
投降。所以她又给他们写了第三封信：你们这些英国人，对法兰西王国没有任何权利，天国之王通过我，贞德少女，命令你们放弃据点，回到你们自己的国家。如果不这样做，我将发出一个
war cry that will be remembered forever. I am writing this to you for the third and last time. I will write no more. And she ties the letter to an arrow and has it fired into the English camp and the response is the familiar one. Basically, piss off, you whore. Yeah. Armagnac haw, they call her. Interesting. A reminder that there is an element of a civil war to this as well as a war between the French and English, right? Burgundians and Armagnac's. Yeah. So the English clearly are not going to withdraw. And so Joan and the French captains decide, well, we're going to continue attacking them. And so on dawn the next day, which is the 6th of May, Joan makes confession. She hears mass. And then she joins hundreds of French soldiers who are clambering into boats, crossing the Loire
永远被铭记的战争呐喊。这是我第三次也是最后一次写信给你们。我不会再写了。她把信绑在箭上，射向英国军营，回应是熟悉的。基本上就是，滚开，你这个妓女。是的。他们称她为“阿马尼亚克的妓女”。有趣。提醒人们，这既是法国和英国之间的战争，也包含内战的成分，对吧？勃艮第派和阿马尼亚克派。是的。所以英国人显然不会撤退。于是贞德和法国队长们决定，好吧，我们将继续攻击他们。第二天黎明，也就是5月6日，贞德进行了忏悔。她参加了弥撒。然后她加入了数百名爬上船只的法国士兵，
in a great flotilla to an island in the middle of the river. And then from that island, a pontoon is made out of the bridges. And soldiers start. crossing it onto the South Bank. And the goal of this operation is to flush the English out of the Great Augustinian Priory and the Tower of Létrell so that they will then be cleared pretty completely from the Southern Bank. And Glastdale, the ex-Archer, the captain of Le Torel, will no longer be able to menace O'Leon with his artillery. Joan is on the Southern Bank, isn't she? She's with all her cronies. is. So there's the bastard. There's that bloke Lair, the wrath of God. And there's a third guy.
组成一支庞大的船队穿过卢瓦尔河，到达河中间的一个岛屿。然后从那个岛上，用桥梁搭建了一个浮桥。士兵们开始穿过它到达南岸。这次行动的目标是将英国人从伟大的奥古斯丁修道院和图雷尔塔中赶出来，这样他们就能被彻底从南岸清除。前弓箭手、图雷尔的队长格拉斯代尔将无法再用他的火炮威胁奥尔良。贞德在南岸，对吧？她和她所有的伙伴在一起。是的。有私生子。有那个叫拉伊尔的家伙，上帝的愤怒。还有第三个人。
Now, I always think you should judge somebody by the company they keep. And this is a lord from Brittany. And he's got quite a reputation, hasn't he, for all kinds of activities. And he's called Gilles de Rhe. Well, at this point, Dominic, he has a reputation as a very proficient guerrilla leader. Yeah. In due course, he will have a reputation for other things. And we may come to that in due course. But at this point, his reputation like that of the Bastavolio and Lair is as a very proficient captain of men. And so these three men with Joan are leading the attack on the English positions in the Priory and Létreu. When the captains reach the priory, they're right up against it. And they think, oh, actually, I don't know. I mean, this looks a bit quite a tough
我一直认为你应该通过一个人结交的朋友来判断他。这是一个来自布列塔尼的领主。他以各种活动而闻名，不是吗？他叫吉尔·德·雷。嗯，多米尼克，此时他以一名非常精干的游击队领袖而闻名。是的。在适当的时候，他会因其他事情而闻名。我们以后可能会谈到这一点。但在此时，他的名声就像奥尔良私生子和拉伊尔一样，是一位非常精干的军队队长。所以这三个人和贞德一起领导了对英国人在修道院和图雷尔阵地的攻击。当队长们到达修道院时，他们遇到了困难。他们想，哦，实际上，我不知道。我的意思是，这看起来有点难
nut to crack. And they think, oh, maybe we should delay. Maybe we should try and get some more reinforcements. But Joan, she's not having any of it. She says, we've got this. We're ready to do it. And Leir agrees. And so the whole mass of the French forces gathered in front of the priory, they surge towards the walls of the priory, and they break over it. And even though the English fight bravely, the French are able to sweep them aside. They pile into the prior itself, the English withdraw, and they retreat into the great tower of L'Etrell. And Joan, again, despite the fact that she has just trodden on the spike of a caltrap. So those are those kind of weapon, you know, those kind of booby traps that they put to stop horses.
啃。他们想，哦，也许我们应该推迟。也许我们应该尝试获得更多的增援。但贞德，她根本不听。她说，我们能行。我们准备好了。拉伊尔也同意了。于是聚集在修道院前的所有法国军队涌向修道院的墙壁，并突破了它。尽管英国人勇敢地战斗，但法国人还是能够将他们扫除。他们涌入修道院本身，英国人撤退，退入了图雷尔大塔。贞德，尽管她刚刚踩到了铁蒺藜的尖刺。就是那种武器，你知道，那种他们用来阻止马匹的陷阱。
So she's limping, but no, she doesn't care about that. She's all for launching a massive attack. But she is in pain. And so she's kind of, they say, the captains say, well, look, I think you should maybe retreat, you know, go and have it tended to have a few plasters or whatever. And so she, Jane says, yeah, all right. And so she withdraws to the camp. But once she's gone, the remaining captains, they hold a council of war, and they agree that
所以她在跛行，但她不在乎。她一心只想发动大规模进攻。但她很痛苦。所以他们说，队长们说，好吧，看，我想你也许应该撤退，你知道，去处理一下，贴几块膏药什么的。于是贞德说，好吧，没问题。于是她撤回了营地。但她一走，剩下的队长们就召开了战争会议，他们一致认为
they don't actually have the numbers to attack Leite Relle. They may have taken the priory, but Leite Rell is just too formidable. You know, it's the largest, it's the most heavily defended fortress the English have. And therefore, it would be insane to launch an attack against it. That's fair enough. But Joan doesn't like that, does she? Because when she finds out about it that evening, she goes absolutely ballistic. And she says, come on, God wants us to do this.
他们实际上没有足够的人数来攻击图雷尔。他们可能占领了修道院，但图雷尔实在太令人生畏了。你知道，这是英国人拥有的最大、防御最严密的堡垒。因此，对它发动攻击是疯狂的。这很公平。但贞德不喜欢这样，对吧？因为当她那天晚上发现这件事时，她彻底爆发了。她说，来吧，上帝希望我们这样做。
What are you thinking? You need to change your mind. Yeah. And she says, you know, you captains, you've conferred among yourselves. But I, Joan, I have conferred with God. Yeah. So the next morning there's another council of war. And Joan succeeds in persuading, you know, changing their minds.
你们在想什么？你们需要改变主意。是的。她说，你们这些队长，你们在你们之间商量过了。但我，贞德，我已经和上帝商量过了。是的。所以第二天早上又召开了一次战争会议。贞德成功地说服了他们，改变了他们的主意。
They say, yeah, all right. Okay. Let's go for it. And to quote, Husinga, the, the, the, the great Dutch historian we quoted in the previous episode. It is clear, I think, that it's tempting to think this is kind of a lunatic approach. She's just kind of saying attack, attack, attack. But I think it does touch something deep in the hearts of the French captains. You know, they sense a kind of a quality of heroism to it. So to quote Huisinger, her courage and her confidence,
他们说，好吧，没问题。好的。让我们行动吧。引用我们上一集引用的伟大的荷兰历史学家赫伊津哈的话。我认为，很明显，人们很容易认为这是一种疯狂的方法。她只是在说进攻，进攻，进攻。但我认为这确实触动了法国队长们内心深处的东西。你知道，他们感觉到了一种英雄主义的品质。所以引用赫伊津哈的话，她的勇气和自信，
these are the most immediate elements of her nature and the ones that give the most tangible explanation of her success, a greatness that manifests itself in a superior, irresistible and infectious bravery. And I think that infectious bravery, the captains pick up on it. As a result, on the 7th of May 1429, the fateful decision is taken to attack L'etorrell, and this is a decision that it may be determines the course of the Hundred Years' War. Okay. So waves after waves of French attacks are launched on the Great Keep of L'Orel. The goal is to bridge the ditch that surrounds the tower with brushwood and then to bring ladders, to put them on the side of the walls and to climb up.
这是她天性中最直接的元素，也是对她成功最具体的解释，一种体现在卓越、不可抗拒和具有感染力的勇敢中的伟大。我认为那种具有感染力的勇敢，队长们感受到了。结果，1429年5月7日，决定攻击图雷尔的命运性决定做出了，这可能决定了百年战争的进程。好的。所以一波又一波的法国进攻对图雷尔大塔发动了。目标是用灌木丛填平塔周围的沟渠，然后带上梯子，把它们架在墙边爬上去。
Joan is with an attack party. There's a ladder. She climbs up the ladder. And as she does so, she's hit in the neck by a crossbow bolt. She's knocked backwards off the ladder and she drops her banner into the. the mud that's being churned up by all the men at arms. And so there's a great cheer goes up from the English, and obviously the morale of the French is pretty badly dented. Joan is led away. The French attack flags. The Bastard of Orleans decides, well, I think, you know, this attack
贞德和一支突击队在一起。有一个梯子。她爬上梯子。就在这时，她的脖子被一支弩箭射中。她从梯子上向后摔倒，把她的旗帜掉进了被所有武装士兵搅得泥泞不堪的泥地里。于是英国人发出了一阵欢呼，显然法国人的士气受到了相当大的打击。贞德被带走了。法国人的进攻减弱了。奥尔良私生子决定，好吧，我想，你知道，这次进攻
isn't going to work. We should call it off. We'll wait for the morning. We'll bring over artillery from Alleyon. We've got all this ammunition. We'll have a crack again the next day. But Joan Squire, Jean Doulon, who is a big fan of Joan by this point, he picks up her banner, he begins climbing up the ladder, still brandishing it, you know, war cries, left, right and center, all the other soldiers see this, they start following Jean up his ladder, they start putting up their own ladders, they're all piling up, and Joan, who is standing on the edge of the ditch, yelling encouragement, she urges the bastard. Come on, we've got this. Let's renew the attack. And the bastard of Ollion is persuaded. And so the attack continues. And meanwhile, on the far side of the river,
不会成功。我们应该取消它。我们等明天早上。我们会从奥尔良运来火炮。我们有这么多弹药。我们第二天再试一次。但贞德的侍从让·杜隆，此时他是贞德的忠实粉丝，他捡起她的旗帜，开始爬上梯子，仍然挥舞着它，你知道，到处都是战争呐喊，所有其他士兵看到这一幕，他们开始跟着让爬上他的梯子，他们开始架起自己的梯子，他们都涌了上去，而站在沟渠边缘大声鼓励的贞德，她敦促私生子。来吧，我们能行。让我们重新发起进攻。奥尔良私生子被说服了。于是进攻继续。与此同时，在河的另一边，
the townsmen of Ollion have got these great wooden planks. And they are laying these planks over the gap in the bridge that they demolished so that they can, so that the arch is bridged. And their aim is to cross this kind of makeshift bridge and attack Le Torel from the opposite side to the attack that's being launched by Joan and the Bastard of O'Leon, so that effectively the English in the keep will be completely surrounded. And the English defenders recognizing this begin to panic, and their commander, this much feared, much hated, incredibly intimidating ex-archer, Sir William Glastdale, he loses his footing. He plummets into the river and of course he's weighed down by his armour and so he sinks to the bottom.
奥尔良的市民们拿着这些巨大的木板。他们把这些木板铺在他们拆毁的桥梁缺口上，以便桥拱能够连接起来。他们的目标是穿过这种临时桥梁，从与贞德和奥尔良私生子发起的进攻相反的方向攻击图雷尔，这样塔里的英国人实际上就会被完全包围。英国守军意识到这一点后开始恐慌，他们的指挥官，那个令人恐惧、令人憎恨、极其令人生畏的前弓箭手威廉·格拉斯代尔爵士，他失去了平衡。他坠入河中，当然他被盔甲压得沉了下去，沉到了河底。
Oh no! That is the end of him. And with the loss of their commander, the English effectively give up and they are massacred by the victorious French, 500 men in all are slaughtered. And so by the evening the Tower of Litterelle, the priory, both of them are in French hands and the victors rather than return to aureon by boats are able to return to the city across the wooden planks that have been laid across the river and of course you know there's an absolute mood of ecstasy bells are peeling crowds are cheering joan is the
哦，不！那是他的结局。随着指挥官的损失，英国人实际上放弃了抵抗，他们被胜利的法国人屠杀，总共500人被杀。所以到了晚上，图雷尔塔、修道院，两者都落入了法国人手中，胜利者没有乘船返回奥尔良，而是能够通过铺在河上的木板返回城市，当然，你知道，那是一种绝对狂喜的情绪，钟声在响，人群在欢呼，贞德是
heroine of the moment and what about the english so the english back out in their kind of siege their encampments and whatnot. So you've got Suffolk and Tallbert and Scales, all these kind of hard-bitten captains, and they're pretty downcast now, aren't they? Because they've lost a lot of men. They've lost their principal sort of forts for prosecuting the siege.
当下的女英雄，那英国人呢？所以英国人退回了他们的围城营地之类的。所以你有萨福克、塔尔博特和斯凯尔斯，所有这些久经沙场的队长，他们现在很沮丧，不是吗？因为他们损失了很多人。他们失去了围城的主要堡垒。
They've also crucially lost control of the bridge and the river, so Orlyan can now get supplies and reinforcements from the South. And basically, the game is up for them in Orlingo, right? Yeah. They've got no prospect of success. and the English commanders recognize this. Obviously, they're anxious to save face. And so Suffolk, the guy who's an overall command,
他们还关键地失去了对桥梁和河流的控制，所以奥尔良现在可以从南方获得补给和增援。基本上，他们在奥尔良的比赛结束了，对吧？是的。他们没有任何成功的希望。英国指挥官也意识到了这一点。显然，他们急于挽回面子。所以萨福克，那个总指挥，
he draws his men up in formation, essentially challenging the French to a pitch battle. But of course, you know, I mean, the French don't need to do it. They came here to relieve Ollion. They've relieved it. So why would they risk losing it all again by taking on the English bowmen? So an hour passes, the English give up. They turn around and they start marching north.
他把他的部下排成阵型，本质上是挑战法国人进行一场正面交锋。但当然，你知道，我的意思是，法国人不需要这样做。他们来这里是为了给奥尔良解围。他们已经解围了。所以他们为什么要通过对抗英国弓箭手来冒着再次失去它的一切风险呢？所以一个小时过去了，英国人放弃了。他们转身开始向北行军，
away from Aureoleon, the siege is over. So the siege had lasted for six months, but in four days, Joan and the French have been able to relieve the city. And to the dauphin and to those who support him, this seems like, you know, she's delivered on her promises. The miracle from God was foretold, and it has duly arrived. Yeah. I mean, it absolutely strikes the dauphin and everybody who supports him as a miracle.
远离奥尔良，围城结束了。所以围城持续了六个月，但在四天内，贞德和法国人就能够解围了。对于王储和那些支持他的人来说，这看起来像是，你知道，她兑现了她的承诺。上帝的奇迹被预言了，并且如期而至。是的。我的意思是，这绝对让王储和所有支持他的人感到这是一个奇迹。
This victory seems to have come from nowhere. soldiers whose morale was at rock bottom now seem, you know, possessed with an absolute confidence that God is on their side and that victory for them is inevitable. And they attribute this miracle to one person, to Joan the maid. And this is the news, for instance, that brought to Christine de Pazin, the great poet in the Abbey, in seclusion, in silence, she's been so despondent. it's what inspires her to start writing poetry again. Christine writes about Joan.
这场胜利似乎是凭空而来的。士气跌入谷底的士兵们现在似乎被一种绝对的自信所占据，认为上帝站在他们这一边，他们的胜利是不可避免的。他们把这个奇迹归功于一个人，贞德少女。这就是带给克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑的消息，这位伟大的诗人在修道院里，在隐居中，在沉默中，她一直如此沮丧。这正是激励她重新开始写诗的原因。克里斯蒂娜写了关于贞德的作品。
The beauty of her life proves that she has been blessed with God's grace. How clear this was at the siege of Aureon. It is my belief that never was a miracle more evident. Crikey. Well, the story of Joan of Arc is, of course, not yet over, because she has promised that she will lead the Dauphan de Rojas for his coronation and drive the English out of France, and we'll discover whether or not they do that.
她生命的美丽证明了她得到了上帝的恩典。在奥尔良之围中，这一点是多么清晰。我相信，从来没有比这更明显的奇迹了。天哪。好吧，圣女贞德的故事当然还没有结束，因为她承诺她将带领王储去加冕，并将英国人赶出法国，我们将发现他们是否做到了这一点。
and we will also turn to the question that is now on the Englishman's minds. Is Joan really sent from God, or is she, as the trial will prove, a witch? Now, if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can hear those episodes right now. You don't need to wait. If you'd like to join our club members and enjoy all the amazing benefits that they take great pleasure from every day, then just head to the rest of history.com. But we will be back to find out what happens next in this extraordinary story and to examine exactly what was going on in Joan of Arc's head.
我们还将转向现在英国人心中的问题。贞德真的是上帝派来的吗，还是像审判所证明的那样，她是一个女巫？现在，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以听到这些剧集。你不需要等待。如果你想加入我们的俱乐部成员并享受他们每天都乐在其中的所有惊人福利，那么只需前往restofhistory.com。但我们将回来看看在这个非凡故事的接下来发生了什么，并仔细检查圣女贞德脑子里到底在想什么。
So on that bombshell, Tom, merci, and au revoir. Avovoire. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，谢谢，再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。